[Music]
good evening everybody i'm josh welch
with film independent
thank you all for being here tonight
without further ado join me in welcoming
the one and only jake gyllenhaal
okay thank you
this is the first q a i've done in four
years so
i'm trying to get used to the director's
chair again
i slip off
thank you for being here and congrats on
the film it's so fantastic
9-1-1 what is the address of your
emergency
[Music]
i just want to talk to you okay i'm
hanging out just stop for a drive
sweetie okay
is there someone with you
is the person who didn't know you called
us no what do they think you called your
child yes sweetie does the person you're
with have a weapon yes i need to color
the car okay when i say the right one
say it's fine red
white
there is a scared little girl whose
mother has been abducted i need a better
local audition how will you get it
i know emily's with you
where are you going
i need you to pull the handbrake hard
i had seen
[Music]
the original film gustav muller's
original film out of sundance
and as soon as i saw it i immediately
thought first of all i thought
he's an incredible filmmaker and i
thought
who is this guy i really want to meet
him and um
and then i thought this also i thought
the film
something in my bones told me that
transposing that idea into an american
context
would have a power that it didn't
necessarily have when it was in
denmark said in denmark
and something made me feel like we could
redo it so we we got the rights for my
company and developed the movie for two
years and i think there's a lot of wrote
the draft and then
at a certain point we were looking for
projects
uh when the pandemic hit that we could
possibly make even when it looked like
nothing could be made and this really
fit the bill in a lot of ways
it was contained it had one person in it
and i had always wanted to shoot it in
five days i had always had that vision
of
wanting to do the film in five days we
settled on 11 days
but uh it all started came together and
i when i pitched it to antoine i sent it
to antoine who was a friend because
we've made another movie together and
i've been looking for something to do
for a number of years
i said we can shoot this i know you're
only available for five days um in the
in the coming year we can shoot it in
five days so when you read it just keep
that in mind and uh he read in the next
day he called me and he said i'm in
let's do this wow
so from the beginning was it from the
beginning for you always going to be set
in los angeles
no that was an antoine ad
initially was in another city
and he
he just said i you know just the nature
of los angeles obviously it means a lot
to him uh he felt it as um
an extension in some ways of of training
day in that space in that world and and
then i i had done a movie here also
called end of watch and
which is written by david ayer who wrote
training day and so there were these
connections i felt we felt los angeles
culturally was the right space to put it
in
he wanted to communicate
where we were in where i don't
permanently live in the city anymore but
i grew up here so i'm sorry to keep
staying where we were but
where i think this city is and where the
the state finds itself in particular the
west with all these wildfires
so i think there was a lot of things
that you felt were was
very they were really appropriate for
los angeles
it's even though it's all set in that
one room
it feels like such an la story
and i mean for the reasons you just said
and
you've done you've done a lot of great
la films like i will end the watch and
nightcrawler this one feels of a piece
of that in a way where the city is such
a key part of it
yeah i mean l.a at night you know
there's nothing like it um
and i i yeah i think there's i don't
know why but
i think there's something about the
surface of los angeles during the day
you know i think that there's obviously
we are known or is known as a city
that has a lot of shine and a lot of
presentation during the day
and i think at night what is presented
is potentially maybe more of a truth
about what's actually happening with us
and
underneath all of us
and i think that's a beautiful thing
so i tend to gravitate towards those
spaces maybe and i think los angeles is
so
dark and
complex
in so many ways and it's
endlessly cinematic and i don't think
i'm the first person that felt that way
or feels that way about it
it's crazy to hear you shot it in 11
days um even though it's contained in
one location in you it's still
that that's kind of
staggering to hear could you talk about
what you just like the nuts and bolts of
shooting during covet how you approached
it because you were shooting in in the
fall of 2020 yeah october yeah october
2020 so that was like the height of it
things were
it was
yeah it was
every day was a potential lockdown you
know
i think we decided obviously that we
were going to shoot in 11 days
we were at the beginning of all of this
and i think none of us really
knew what would happen
i think we thought it was advantageous
that we were going to shoot it in a very
short period of time and then what we
realized was the friday before we
started shooting on that
month we were supposed to start shooting
on the monday
antoine was near someone who tested
positive for covet so it meant he had to
go into quarantine
and so uh
it was right before production this was
two days before supposed to start
shooting wow
so it meant
obviously
given all of the restrictions and all of
the insurance issues and our bonding and
now on top of the covet insurance we
didn't really know what was going to
happen and would we lose cash that we
had asked for favors i mean we had
i had called up paul dano and i called
up my brother-in-law and and antoine
called up ethan hawk and said you want
to come work these days i said sure
we're free we had this incredible cast
like
about to work and we had a director who
wasn't able to be there
um
and so
we put together everyone sort of put
together ideas and we came up with what
if we put antoine in this van there's a
van we had a wonderful group of
producers that had
that had uh
um
they had
screens on it you know and and and and
he could communicate to the set through
wakitaki and also through particular
communication devices in the van
um
and we try we set it up applause for the
van
absolutely
um not the white van but the van
and so we set up
this this van at his house and there was
this delay this quarter of second delay
between his sound and his image and he
was going crazy he's like i can't do
this we did this on a saturday
and then someone suggested what if we
hardwire the van to the stage where we
were shooting
and park it a block away
and and then he'll be away he
subsequently tested negative over three
days so he said he's okay
um but he has to stay in quarantine so
let's just do that so we hardwired his
van a block away to the stage and he
directed the entire movie
from a van down the street
um that is insane yeah i mean we we felt
that way when we've discovered and it
worked you know we applauded too it was
it saved the movie and it was such an
interesting process i mean i don't want
to speak for him though i've heard him
speak about it
we and he would say that he we were both
very isolated um
both the character that i play
and him and somehow he was in joe's
position too it was this weird thing
where there he is in front of these
three screens and he's directing a movie
about a guy in front of these three
screens
and we would facetime in between so we
we crazy we separated the movie into
five parts
um five acts essentially each 20 pages
and we shot those 20 pages each day
20 minute long takes so we would
choreograph and rehearse like
you would
something theatrical
and then we would roll for 20 minutes
and we did about
eight to ten takes a day sometimes more
and then we would you know
get into specifics and we you know of
every setup that's how much we'd have
three cameras sort of all the time and
so
um
man all the technical issues of this
movie were very interesting all the
actors were on zoom
they would come in and they'd be on zoom
and then our first cd would cue them and
then
i would hear them in my ear but not see
them and
antoine would have them on a computer
and
you mean everyone that you were
interacting with on the phone was on
that section yes it was on zoom yeah so
you had paul dano in australia you had
uh
peter stars got in new york you had
riley keough in los angeles you had
ethan hawk in new york two blocks away
from peter sarsgaard um
in the coolest part of brooklyn um
and you know you so you you you had all
these people and they were cueing them
and what we what i didn't realize
was that zoom as we all probably know
now
doesn't really allow for interruption
and i don't know how you all feel but i
feel like some of the best part of
acting is
rhythm
and interruption
and
zoom was dictating that for us
um it was like the beginning of a zoom
when you get on and everyone tries to
say hi and everyone's like
oh yeah no and then your yellow square
lights up and you go hi you know it was
like
that you know and threw out a scene and
so we had to navigate our way through
being restricted by this
new weird medium
um
did you have it in your ear yeah wow
okay
yeah and my director down the block you
know so it was really he in your ear as
well or you would talk to him between
takes he was not in my ear he was on a
walkie
there were three walkies there was
kewwaki walking for him to note me and
then when we were setting up
we were changing setups we would either
facetime each other so i could put on an
earphone and hear him quietly he could
note me
quietly or i'd go outside climb a ladder
over to the top of the wall
and he would come out of his van down
the block
and he would scream notes at me
from the street
like romeo and juliet
[Laughter]
it was quite quite quite an experience
but i will say in in all the in all in
all seriousness i think we were all so
grateful to be working and so grateful
to be there
that we would have done anything and we
pretty much did
to make sure that we could make this
movie
yeah wow that's incredible
um
so
your performance i mean you're in
literally every frame of the film
it is tight on your face a lot
and sorry about that yeah
um
i'd love to hear you talk about how you
essentially how you built the
performance because how do you modulate
that over the course of a film i mean
are you just doing sort of
moment-to-moment work with the other
actors and
living through it are you thinking
about the scope of the film as you're
going through each section
well we always thought of it very
theatrically i mean antoine mentioned
sailing city lumet a lot um
and we always thought that
this was a character that existed in his
own reality in a lot of ways the movie
is a fantasy right um
the admittance at the end the the the
the ability to communicate that kind of
truth in the position he's in is a
fantasy
um that is not something we see people
in his position do
and it's necessary to communicate that
and that's what we both felt um i think
that's what antoine felt very strongly
and so it meant i knew that
it wasn't
existing in a space of normal it was
existing in a space of a sort of
dreamlike space so emotions could be
much bigger i knew i could
no i could
i could calibrate it probably instead of
one to ten i could calibrate it one
maybe 14
and all the other people in that space
were sort of living in a mundane world
so
you know from the beginning i think this
guy's holding on to a lot
and there's a lot of toxicity in him
and
he's putting it on to other people like
blame blame blame blame blame
and the first section was really the
labeled sort of blame
um
and then slowly
i did just specifically when you're
working with wonderful actors
um
start to listen i mean a lot of the
performances
what i love about i had spent a year
doing a show on off-broadway first and
then on broadway the year before it was
a monologue
and my favorite part of that show
was when i could like viscerally feel
the audience switch on and their
imaginations turn off turn on and i
disappeared
it was like i started to speak and tell
a story
and then
i disappeared and
their life
started to appear to them and i thought
this
is what
we could do cinematically and i just
knew a lot of the movie was about
listening and i knew that at a certain
point if you have good enough actors on
the other end of the line that listening
would become the audience creating their
own story
um
and i had faith in that and then a lot
of it was
also where we were in the world at the
time the pressure and being able to
exercise all those feelings of
um
everything that was going on
it's interesting you mentioned sidney
lumet i found myself thinking about him
watching the film or i don't know like
because you were bored or because i was
bored i was like i should
i should really watch dog day afternoon
no no i i don't know there was some i i
found myself thinking about
film noir in certain segments of this it
felt very noirish like the i don't know
the guilty man the broken man
um
obviously stylistically in the lighting
but the i don't know your character felt
noirish but then also like sydney lumet
who does these
dramas with very like intense singular
characters but where there's like social
issues playing throughout at the same
time which clearly you had that here
um
and was that was that in the danish film
as well or was this
or was it probably a different set of
issues
uh the the uh
again i think in my mind i
something in my bones and also with with
antoine i think we felt in america
[Music]
when you when you when you put the idea
of mental health
into
a story
it changes it because what it does is it
calls out our systems which are broken
so yeah um
no it wasn't the same it was not the
same sort of
uh it was a it was a much subtler
um very
extraordinary film i mean it's an
extraordinary film
but i think
like for instance
having another performer perform hamlet
or perform you know whatever slew of
characters
which we do on the stage all the time
i felt like
those social issues changed when you
changed the person when you changed the
location
and
um
we both felt it necessary so yeah i mean
antoine the first thing antoine said to
me was he was like this movie's about
mental health
um
and i said
yeah i mean do you want to do it um but
yes you know i felt the same
yeah um we talked a little bit about
this backstage but could you talk about
sort of uh
the cameras and like how it was shot
physically through
there's a different range throughout the
film but um again because it's so it's
just on you it's your face were you sort
of working with the cinematographer like
did you know what lenses he had on you
at any given moment or how you were
framed in the shot or were you just like
just doing your your stuff as an actor
um
well first of all i mean when you're
working with a visualist like antoine
i'm not really concerned about any of
that stuff i just know he has a language
and he's so fluent in it and he's
such a wonderful
visualist that i just don't have any you
know you can relax you know i don't
think about that though
when those three cameras are on you and
the six or eight people are
around you all the time who are in
charge of those cameras and then slowly
as the movie as we shot the movie over
the
um 11 days the camera started to move
closer to me and the lens lenses were
changed so that by the end of the movie
the cameras were six inches from my face
i had
i had literally i was surrounded by
cameramen and women
it was like
if the pressure wasn't enough it was
like all i was worried it was i was just
gonna fog up the lens like in the
shot you know but there was this extra
additive pressure of the choreography of
the cameras that antoine always knew he
was going to do just through lens choice
and so i was stuck like
i was stuck there was a tension from the
operators
they were
they were tense the focus was tense
capturing me was tense and right they
didn't know what i was gonna do there
were a couple there were many moments
where it was extraordinarily frustrating
and also there's stuff going on in your
ear you have
at the by the end of the movie you have
three phones
you know um and by the way none of them
really ringing you just have to remember
which who's calling and if you're
calling someone right um and i was so
grateful at a certain point that i was
just talking to emily for a big section
of the end even though everything that
we were talking about was so terrible
that i didn't have to talk i didn't have
to answer a phone you know
but i think that that was the pressure
of that
uh
was thought through the actual physical
pressure of the cameras and also just
entrapping me
you know and embarrassing me frankly
it's i don't find it i'm not an actor
who finds it like
um
[Music]
i don't love a close-up it's not
something i'm like waiting for you know
i i there are many actors who do they
wait for their close-up and that's their
thing it's just not who i am
and so when someone puts a camera that
close to my face
i feel embarrassed
you know and so um
i felt very embarrassed you know i mean
we all know we look i mean
yeah
you guys know what i'm talking about
um
i think i the
there's that long conversation between
you and emily at the end that's
incredibly powerful just emotionally
what's going on like with what's going
on with her and then the moment when you
tell her that you killed a man i mean
that
like
i and i was thinking in there i mean so
you were hearing her live that was riley
keough
so you were hearing her she was on zoom
and you were hearing the audio of that
and playing off that in that moment
yeah everything was live wow we tried
many things we tried recording it we
tried oh
with the scene with the young kid who
only had a number of hours we recorded
her
and then that that didn't work all the
time so then we had someone just reading
lines off-camera for a little bit of
time but yes with with riley
and i will say
you know she
you know i don't think i'm saying
anything that is not known but she's
been through a very very difficult
couple of years
and
there are there are currents of the same
ideas
um
the loss that she's gone through in this
story
and um
i can it was so brave of her to face
those things i think
sort of cathartic for her to face those
things and so we would be in the middle
of these live takes and
um
all of those things that were going on
that she was feeling not that she wanted
to do that but she's been through things
like that with people she loves
um
so brave of her to to put those feelings
out there and so i yeah everything was
live and
i think some of those big feelings that
you see
and they do play differently in a
close-up but i think those big feelings
like
they were all true to our exchange in
the moment um
and oftentimes it's so weird we would
cut
be a long long take and then i would
like call her on the phone
you know
be like are you okay you know
so i was like
yeah from a phone to a phone to phone to
phone and then my fucking director's on
a phone and everyone's on the phone you
know
um i mean that's how we all feel i know
but it was like that it was just like
and then it was like you know
and then you get off you're going home
and you just call everybody on the phone
again and like and then you're alone in
a room calling me on phone so it was
just it was like it was it was a really
interesting experience wow yeah
um
no i i mean no you're describing what
life is like now it's weird to be in a
theater with humans you know it's so
great
like so great
[Music]
um jake i did want to ask you about um
you've been producing a lot lately and
um
in fact more than i was i went to your
imdb page and i was like oh my god he's
like produced on a lot of films that you
act in but then you've also been
producing well some of which are also in
but great independent films like
wildlife and
relic and kind of smaller films with
more and coming people or you know
i'm just and this of course so i'd love
to hear you talk at all what's drawing
you to producing
um
what do you enjoy about that nothing
it's horrible um no
it's not true
um i mean is it is it like a necessity
where it strengthens your
position as an actor or is it because
you just you enjoy the putting projects
together and
well um
you know i think initially what i
started to realize was when i when i
made night crawler the film we talked
about when i made end of watch um
i was
adding things produce early without sort
of realizing it sort of started on end
of watch because i was there for so long
in preparation we prepared for five
months for that movie as actors and
inevitably all the choices start you
start being involved in the choices i
also come from a storytelling background
more so even than a performing
background so telling stories and being
a part of and watching it was is in my
my blood somewhere
um
and so
with nightcrawler i realized though you
know
it's really interesting to be there
early and be a part of those those
discussions and and and then help out
and then we started this company with my
partner reeva marker and
um
we both have this vision of
helping people tell their stories the
stories that they won't tell
and to me that's really exciting
i
love the idea of helping people bring
their stories to life
and
if i can be a part of it and
you know
get a little credit for it i love that
you know and
i also love the just the down dirty
process of making movies like
i
i mean
the shiny stuff's nice like
you know it's nice shirt and stuff and
some someone gave it to me or whatever
and that's nice but i really love making
movies you know and
i just want to be in it i just want to
be in it yeah and i want to be in the
shit
you know so
that's the opportunity to do it you know
because actors come in so late i mean
that's what i've realized
we think we're so special and it's like
we've really come at the very last
minute right you know
like a very last minute you know so we
should really shut the fuck up but i i
um no i was here but i but i but i i do
think that's what i love is being there
at the beginning being through all the
monkey stuff all the stuff when you when
you you know it's a wonderful thing even
in the terrible parts when you lose your
you know you think you're going to lose
your director and you have to figure out
how to do it and you all have to do it
together
nothing like teamwork
so i mean to that are you
in addition to producing are you
thinking of directing is that appealing
as well
it is appealing yes
yes it is appealing and i i actually
love actors so much
i know i just sort of talk shit but i
really just love them so much part of my
thing as a as an actor is i think i tend
to
love watching the actor cross for me
sometimes more than what i'm doing
and um
i would say sometimes that's
i
i think it's all it's been speaking to
me for a long time that i should listen
to that
thought
excellent well thank you so much jake
thank you
thank you all so much
thank you
[Music]
you